لاول مره منذ بدايه الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
روسيا تنفذ تدريبات تحاكي صد هجوم مفترض
على العاصمه موسكو قد يكون بالصواريخ او
بغارات تنفذها طائرات او مسيرات غربيه وان
كان بيان الدفاع الروسيه بررها بانها
للتصدي لهجوم مجموعه تخريبيه لعدو وهمي
تكمن اهميه التدريبات في انها تظهر مخاوف
روسيا من تعرض عاصمتها لهجمه مع وصول
اسلحه غربيه متقدمه لاوكرانيا خاصه بعد
تنفيذ هجمات على مناطق حدوديه روسيه مثل
بالجورد وتعرض قواعد عسكريه لهجمات
بمسيرات في عمق الروسي كما حدث في سيرته
ورزان فضلا عن مناطق ذمتها روسيا كالقرم
او لنيتها القيامه بعمليه عسكريه كبيره
تخشى ردا غربيا عليها حيث تتوقع دوائر
المخابرات الغربيه قيام روسيا بعمليه
واسعه في اوكرانيا واحتمال دخول بلاروسيا
معها
نشر انظمه دفاع جوي على اسطح ابنيه في
موسكو يراه البعض تناقضا مع التصريحات
الروسيه التي تؤكد ان مسار العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا يسير على ما يرام
وافق قطط وزاره الدفاع اما عن الاسباب
فيرجع مراقبون الامر للتخوف من امتلاك
اوكرانيا مسيرات يصل مداها الى 1000 كلم
ما يعني وصولها الى العاصمه الروسيه فيما
يرى البعض ان ذلك جزء من الدعايه الروسيه
وذلك عبر اظهار التهديد قد تتعرض له موسكو
لسكان العاصمه وتصوير اوكرانيا على انها
عدو لروسيا ما يزيد التعييده الشعبي لما
تسميها روسيا عمليتها العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى زياده نسبه التطوع
في القوات الروسيه هو ذلك هو حديث عن
تعبئه جديده قد تكون غير معلنه
قال بانه لديه امكانيه للوصول نحو 1000
كلم عبر المسيرات التي طورها ولذلك يمكن
ان تصل الى مدينه موسكو لكن كما قلت ربما
تكون روسيا تحضر الراي العام الروسي من
اجل معركه طويله وادعوا دفاعات جويه على
اسطح المنازل في موسكو مشهد قد يكون الاول
منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهو المشهد
الذي يستحضر تلك الاجواء ويهدد بحرب كبيره
الاكثر من ذلك تدريبات روسيا كانت تهدف
لحمايه منشات عسكريه بدواحي موسكو بنشر
منظومه اس 300 بهدف التصدي لهجوم
بالطائرات والصواريخ البالستيه وهي التي
تملكها حصرا دول النيترو
موسكو سبق وان تعرضت لهجوم في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وتمكن الاتحاد السوفيتي
من وقف تقدم دبابات هتلر نحو المدينه
حينها فهل نحن امام تصعيد جديد في الحرب
باوكرانيا قد يصل مداه الى العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو